so präsentieren wir sind so oft val
thorens ich habe es mir was schönes
eigentlich prima sind frauen mit afro
mit negativen vorurteilen konfrontiert
und gepflegt wird nicht passend auch
nicht schön sie kannte gerne über
griffige holte und rassismus überschuss
werde nur weil ein stück zu einem
fußball show aber hat im schrank auf den
tab gedreht
viele frauen zentrum für alternative zu
einer natürlichen das sind 100 franken
das sind wir ja mehrere hunderte von
franken was gerade auf druck sondern zu
erhören und dafür machen sie alles von
künstlichen frisuren bis zu chemikalien
micro wären die folge
ich bin unterwegs sind solidarischer
wenn sie wussten nicht dann hat sie
meistens dabei rücken mich nimmt es
wundern warum sie sich so wohl fühlt als
mit ihrer natürlichen worden
tritscher ist 27
[Musik]
klar mache dass sie mich dort wohl nur
gelacht ich für mich nicht
selbstverständlich
was sie da macht ist nahm ihr das ganze
in teams zählt muss ihre perücke
vorsichtig lösen
und dann habe ich das gemacht und dann
kann ich
dollar
dann muss ich immer meine eigene haus
das
einfach zum
eigenen natürlich schützen
natürlich lohnt sich
perfekt das sind so die größte vorteil
einer jetzt
ist sie der gesellschaft
gelagert wird
also ich sage jetzt mal wenn ich jetzt
die normale brunner gerade habe ich
mich einfach da und mit anderen habe
mich leider
haben wir durch mich zu er und
hayden erlangen und das schaffe
ich bin mir mit der zeit also ich bin ja
vorher straßen wirklich gerne zu leben
freiheit und wir hatten lange also
haben wir eine eigene halle und da habe
ich
das einfach hinter mir
klicks sind ein
selbstkritischer mittlerweile ist die
liegenschaft zum zweck sammeln
mit all meinen chef spielen aber da
nicht zum spiel eine große
rolle bis frisch ich kann
ganz verschiedene baum mit strom
das sind 400 franken oder das sind ja
mehrere wird die von franken aus je
nachdem was für mich das mal gern hätte
was für vor was für ihre qualität also
jetzt schon
saison zwischen 200 minimum und bei bis
zu 2000 euro pro
weg je nachdem wo wasser so 2000 franken
so wick sind weltweit verbreitet und
sogar die berühmte schwarze frauen zeige
die die hoffen natürlich
die hand und das hat einfach auch so und
erstens und physischer nach wie vor ist
es wo die zeit oder sind die
büros dann gibt es noch den status
[Musik]
glücklich gefunden bitte zwischen wir
haben wir schon telefónica dass ihr die
natürlichen holte öffentlichkeit zeigt
sie müssen überwinden wir als frauen sie
person und dann mit ihrer kamera ihre
holz zeigen
mittlerweile gibt es studio und bücher
zu dem thema ich lerne dass in den usa
schwarze frauen und nun mal so viel geld
für die horus kentvizyon
hand ob der kolonialzeit als umfeld oder
wild gold und ob dann hat sich schwarze
frau versuchte diese menschen hat böse
besiegen die eno erschöpft sie und mir
schon mal von gar nicht bewusst wie
wichtig torfrau mit schlüssel sind bis
ich dann jeden fall gute kollegin kann
wo mir immer wieder gesagt hat du selbst
in horb acer klägers jetzt gültige
privilegiert mit ihnen auch
deutlich dass sie ich besitze cerium sie
daraus einfach bildet das du nicht so
viel investieren für die haare
aus scheiße findet so die haarpflege
tasche
das hab ich einfach mega
kneifen will einfach das glück also das
glück bin ich nicht so schwarz ich reise
immer
die nex 7
der europäische
ist jedenfalls der zuhörer sie will
zudem erfahren haben sind
rechnet einfach offen haben noch keine
heiße spur kommen möchte sollte man sich
jetzt dazu kommentare gestreckt und der
relax je nachdem was ist so chemische
mittel zum teil grad machen
wahrscheinlich ist die
tennisspieler von dem relaxen in den
beschluss gekommen
ich tue mich leben daran gewöhnen die
haare sind auch schön wenn service bus
x4
schon so ich bin nicht schockiert hat
alle immer selbstbewusst die frau wagner
und hanne gemerkt dass sie unter hohem
druck falls nur umso mehr dass sie wird
selbstbewusst mit ihrer natürlichen
hormone
ich bin unterwegs zwischen die
vitale hat auch die 23 jährige hopp
strecke
mittlerweile bevorzugt sie den
natürlichen look
video zeigt gerne die natürliche holt
natürlich heißt aber nicht das ist kein
großer form wie lang trug strommix zum
tor machen ich brauch am morgen zwischen
30 und 40 minuten
dass sie wieder so wertet und amerika
mindestens 40 du alle haare flechten
albig soll ja weil ich werde da hab ich
so 12 zöpfe und du darfst das nicht so
dicht ist gottes r8 lang ich hab so land
und ihr halt machen und den gleichen
ausgang und nachher findet in wien die
zweite person sogar horn und langt man
gerade am liebsten mit der fettigen
haben die minimal und ich möchte mich so
bitten möchten will so bald mit relativ
kurzer zeit
es blieb noch ein einfaches und beasley
und das ist mega schade wenn man hat so
lange bis die wieder schön nachher schön
ausgesehen und und altea altea hand von
deiner lüthi der organe zu machen
hat sie vor ihrem hobby von surinam ist
lammert cdu mit ihrer
mamas hinter hat sie mir sie lernen mit
übergriffigen verhalten und co
ich habe mich sehr aufgeregt
euro kosten
auf der gsoa team schreibt
beträgen die die haare mit plane und
zwar die stehen einfach was so
[Gelächter]
los und dann ein herrlicher ist es
wieder ruhig und hätte und wenn ich
hoffe frau gabi es könnte daran auch
werke wie die höher sind als auch merke
dass ich manchmal
zurückführten berg will ali andere als
lehrer definitiv und da sagt man nicht
vorgestellt dass das so ist also
dass das immer noch so ist deswegen
kann ja der totale habe ich sogar ihk
und das ist verständlich meint sieben
jahre bis das schutzgebiet in den
umfragen mit dem dorf beschwor einfach
immer zu hause
aus welches gefühl von malaysia chuck
noski smaghi schlimmeres muss er vor
gemüse machen ich bin zwei kanzlerin
sind die klassen und ältere schüler
haben mich abgefangen sind street x-type
und darm gefunden doch und standuhren du
bist dunkel doch sein schuss wie ein
urwald mann stück zuschuss wenn ein
buschmann und haben mich abgefangen und
ich halt ventura und kann kolleg hat zum
glück und dann aber der schock sie wie
ich als anarchie und finn und erich den
touren und ich schnell heim zu meiner
mutter sagt und die welt hat mich
geschlagen und geschubst und
wunderschöne natur da und das ist ein
megatrend erlebnis klimatischen zum
glück sind es natürlich ab weil ich nach
einem sturz gab ich das gefühl ich muss
man andere ich muss mich dann mache ich
muss meinen andere dass ich gezeigt dass
ich noch mal verschlagen wird
maximal vorigen ist familie aus dem dorf
werkzyklen die neue spuren sieht es bei
den heimsieg vor sie sind beste
freundinnen will ich
verantworte bergmänner hat mir das
irgendwie also zeit spuren hinterlassen
und ich kann noch gar nicht mich im
spiegel schön gefunden wurde mir ist ein
kleiner schmerz mit megalan haben also
fast schuldig fühlte ich dass wir gar
nicht mitbekommen also ich mal wie das
alles gar nicht bewusst sicher dass sie
irgendwann
sowieso situationen hund wo ich halt
nicht keiner mehr als ein meter hoher
oder rassistische situation aber ich
möchte das nicht bewusst gesehen dass du
für mich so an uns gestellt der mann
später bei allen beliebt ist immer gut
auch und für mich so eigentlich mein
vorbild auch mit sag ich ins krankheit
wurde mir das erst mal fertig macht dies
das community ich habe es gerne greift
links will schaue habe ihre dieser
speziell york an du hast
du das eschweiler bis zu deinem kopf
gegangen aber ich hätte mir gefällt das
steckt das dass du ausfallen wird
ich habe gemacht dass ich sie zum
klavier begleiten lässt kann ich jetzt
durch zurück und treffen und riesch
allaguis
aber das ist jetzt verschoben
die hauptprodukte hafer und aufwuchs
die
extensions und ich die haie auch und da
hat man verschiedenen texturen
navy und kurz lang und da hat man kann
ich ja mal gold und hat eine erwägt russ
machen
nach rollen die glocke haben so beliebt
ich würde eher weniger ganz ehrlich
ganz ganz glatte weniger wänden sind sie
die mittel mittel
zwischen plot und
logik und zwar aus dem grund wieder
hallte das
verstecken damit seine zufällig ist aber
natürlich auch solo gig also darum ich
mache das so wie
zwischen teenager das beliebte und
viel
geschafft mit der
frau strecke natürlich haben chemische
mittel
natürlich haben
das wird bis hinten auf verkauf kann man
schon kaputt verbraucht also richtig los
danach haben wir das heißt einfach so
lange wie möglich da und dort übrig
habt das defekte angeht aber es bleibt
richtig
als ein tropfen das wirklich gesagt hat
aber wieso eigentlich ein was eigentlich
wenn man wie ich glaube es dort auch
darum zu machen 100 zuhörer zum wie ich
finde ein auto zu meinen also schauen
mit freundlichen sieht man jetzt mal auf
die pauke
sie hat glaubt das vor der glotze
dort glaubt das hab ich mich jetzt
selber auch er schätzt wir fest dass
glattes haar präsent ist also das wie
ich bin jetzt selber aussuchen irgendwie
gar kein flug sehen also kein
natürliches 107 rätsel frau wach sein
frauen mit einer team traue glatte haare
jetzt ganz europäisch
kurzhaar und
afro ja das ist ja
das sind wie
vorbilder
und seit ich weiß dass stimmung und
[Musik]
das kaufverhalten
dass frischer und viele andere frauen
sich mit dem mittel verbrannt hand oder
haarausfall überhand ist nicht
verwunderlich
untersuchung zeigt dass die hofstrecke
mittel häufig viel formaldehyd drin hand
chemikalie wo so giftig ist dass der
boden durch sie in ihrer internetseite
vor war und
mit dem gerät hand die haben wir alle
schlecht ihr vorgeworfen
abgewiesen wurden vom chor für wir sie
nicht wissen wie man mit afro rumba oder
sie hier gedacht verschnitten zur sache
kommt tina und honda auf sie selber hat
aber dafür jetzt er entwarf erfahrung
oft macht zürich und heute gar nichts
jetzt mal gut zu machen
die 92 mit ihrem chor versammlung
kärlich ganz auf natürliche look
spezialisiert eine freundin ist schade
und ich da wieder trifft
die mit talent wie man mit afro
herumgeht bis sind new york it
weiterbildung die leute haben einfach
das war noch nicht das wird dir einfach
in der klassischen ausbildung wird nicht
gezeigt
individuell wie du damit klar mit diesem
umgehen kannst es wird einfach aufs haar
betrachtet es wird so geschnitten so
behandelt wie auch andere habe auch
sisal bekanntes gefühl dass man sie nie
hornet können akzeptieren das sind die
gene vorgemacht wurde das not laut die
horsch infield passende spiele software
nämlich wo auch so etwas wie das
aussieht
ungepflegt wild nicht passend auch nicht
schön das ist wahr die leute lieben die
harder anzufassen und tragen aber es
endlich wird es trotzdem nicht irgendwie
anerkannten gewissen positionen oder
angesichts eines gewissen kreisen wird
die berufe
muss danke dass sie ist ja kein film
eigentlich verhindern weil wir unsere
haare an das haus wachsen aus dem kopf
wieso kann man den ich einfach auch so
akzeptieren wie gerade sagen was sagen
hatte wieso ich das überhaupt so dass
rot-schwarz ich raus viele handfeste
glaubt die hanna glaube es geht ganz
ganz ganz weit zurück richtung sklaverei
schon dem punkt hat es angefangen weil
umso ich sag mal europäischer du
aussiehst umso besser hast du's sei es
in der gesellschaft dog mäßig das ist
das was sie vielleicht am schnellsten
noch verändern können oder am
schnellsten an passenden anpassen können
oder
ja das sie
einst als auch etwas besser dass mehr
akzeptiert werden ja
nicht die einzigen timo unterdessen die
natürlich ort repariert philosophie
damen und herren dienen zur mutigen die
eigene 0 kennenzulernen
alle die hier hinkommen wollen sich auf
diesem weg machen
sind vielleicht noch nicht alle so
bereit aber gar nicht für jemanden
verlangen von heute auf jetzt sogar ohne
jerome mit dem froh oder es braucht mehr
zeit weil man verändert natürlich das
eigene spiel das eigene bild oder wenn
man die haare immer flach hatte nach
hinten oder gerade dann hat man ein
anderes bild
von einem mann zwiebeln und damit den
mit den locken halte oder mit dem forum
möchte oder ihnen beistehen neben den
kontinent geben
selbstvertrauen aufbauen zeigen wieder
wie man es machen kann
und zeit geben auf jeden fall
[Gelächter]
sportback nachdem ich stehe ob ihm klar
wird filme dann rief ich mich wieder mit
ihrer
mit so wie es studios k sie produzieren
auch
nicht gerade sie ist steht man
mitnehmen
wo sie lange da können akzeptiert cdu
mittlerweile das gefühl wie sondern auch
mit und hat dort über der flugschreiber
[Musik]
so wie sie wirklich ist
ein emotionaler prozess hast du damals
dass die musiktherapie so dass er ab
jetzt wird wieder durch
jetzt geht es wirklich um ein haar wenn
opa max eyth nach lubmin ahorn oder hat
wird allah und sogar jeden tag aufgeregt
über die blicke ich habe mich arbeiten
laufend an und die dank sei gott sein
kann darum dass ich das gefühl dass ich
so einfach das gefühl probieren
entwickeln das hat mich überzeugt dass
einfach alles komprimiert ist wie die
negative gefühle wie papier filter und
jedes mal wenn ich den blick bekommen
[Musik]
und für den afro songs natürlich
hauskauf
frau wo ihre aufrufe trägt sie
mittlerweile schon linie bewegung und
zudem beweglich passt botschaft forderte
die
mitglieder stärker und frank klinik
hinter auch motivieren die holzträger
will ich als vorbild kann so eine
blockade räumen kann das vielleicht mal
ein häftling see oder so aber sagte ich
bin der schweizer familie aufgewachsen
und und wenn ich die chance handeln kann
es das kavalier zu bringen denn dann
wurde ich schwanger bist bürokratie
stimme nutzen durch
das von ihr oder
[Musik]
mir ist gar nicht bewusst sie was dort
für bioethik hand für gewisse frauen für
mich ist das so selbstverständlich dass
ich nicht so viel machen muss für meine
haare gestört oder aus kranzberg - und
ich muss eigentlich auch nicht angst hat
dass einfache belangt ich finde frau
wünsche der awo ihre froh mit stolz
trägt und das statement wenn sätze cool
das sind vorbilder und genau die
brauchen kinder zum beispiel dass sie
nicht deutlich gemacht
wie cd und alle und auch nicht zu
giftigen mittel griffen
sind darüber wussten dass das grau geht
wo wir gelandet
und was macht das mittel wenn ihr das
gehört
oder hat er selber schon so erfahrungen
gemacht
kommentar und wenn ihr mehr frequenz den
abonnieren den kanal